I want to play with pace this year
that's a huge theme
[Applause]
to the lead young fella Rogier runs down
that path starts the offense on the wing
washington extra pass look at that
buffalo [ __ ] Hornets in yet to go to
their bellies Washington it's got the
last eight for Chicago from Washington
the travel call is not going to change
this to more aware of guys moving their
feet before they took that bomb for
Marvin Williams Monken put to play
keep-away all Jemaine Washington Jr both
his father and his mother play college
basketball at Middle Tennessee State go
legit Boylan choice trust exact Devine
still the flop
[Applause]
Corner three Washington 16 shots at
first habits were steamed
[Applause]
Washington killing fields oh man
friendly fire huh
[Applause]
find a shoe Devante he's slow to get up
those five on four closing into the one
minute mark of the third
[Applause]
and the chair take it out from
underneath it numbers for the locals
grab Malik monk
a good job here tonight Zach wanted to
get in a hurry
transition free
he's played does he say he has no set
rotation never games will be a different
scale
[Applause]